can be put on a bright lipstick no one
can say you didn't try but they can say
you tried too hard hey guys it is Friday
which means normally it would be fried
re however I didn't vlog anything this
week I know I was too busy putting
lipstick on apparently it's been a very
busy week in a very mundane way so it
wasn't very vlog worthy lots of sitting
at a computer writing trying to get work
done
not necessarily the greatest content but
who's to say this is any better
also most my week now gets captured on
snapchat so you should be following me
over there real grace Helbig for things
like this
instead one of the things that I've done
a lot of this week is open up things
that I ordered from the internet and
kind of forgot about and then they got
delivered you probably know based on the
title already that this is an adult
essentials haul because everything I'm
about to show you is essential to my
adult life and I will prove it let's
start off really simply
I ordered a giant rattan flamingo it's
probably a little over three feet tall
look at it and you're probably saying
how is this an adult essential and to
that I say stop this isn't essential
because I can put it on the wall and if
anyone breaks into my house at night
they're gonna think one this girl's
crazy too oh my god I broke into a zoo
instead of a house there's nothing for
me here let's leave or three there's a
giant rattan flamingo on the wall
clearly that's a sign that there's
nothing of value in this home let's try
the next one
artistic protection and that is also
what I will call the brand of condoms
that I come out with I don't give items
that I own name I just feel like that's
too much snacks D batteries the outcasts
of the battery world and not like
outcasts like the band cool outcasts as
in like who needs these I need these the
microphone on top of this camera that I
sincerely hopes turn down and working
requires one day battery that should
have been a red flag at this microphone
not helpful D batteries like that one
friend you have that knows how to do
like CPR but is really really
uninteresting in so many other ways and
so he's always at the party's no really
talk to him because he's very awkward
and then one time we have a party to
Lake and someone starts drowning and
you're like oh where's Kevin he knows
how to do CPR and he's not there that's
LG batteries are they're always there
when you don't need them and then when
you need them they decided to go like
bowling or something
adult essential next this I got this off
Jassa main comm to I think and it's um
a fake plant that you're supposed to put
pens and pencils into it works
why have pens and pencils like all over
the place when you can have them in this
and be like look I'm more interesting in
my accessories than I am in conversation
adult essential yeah dad not all the
jewelry just the jewelry holder I got
this at Target when I went to get just
light bulbs and ended up with a few
hundred dollars worth of things later
zap it to the best of us and it brings
out the worst in us this internal
essential because it lets me know that
there are so many directions and as an
adult it's very important to know that
there is more to life than one direction
so this is essential next light bulbs
isn't that symbolic it's not glowing
vibration resistant well thank God cuz I
like to dance I got these light bulbs
because the lights in my bathroom where
I do all of my makeup have a very
yellowish tone so when I leave my house
after I've done my makeup and I see my
makeup in natural lighting I go oh my
gosh
see I did this in my bathroom these says
these before and after pictures here
which you can't see it all are supposed
to be like a more true to natural
lighting kind of lighting maybe I'm just
making that up they're dimmable aren't
we all knack these these are two yellow
storage cubes that I got with Joss and
main calm I'm obsessed with storage
cubes and I don't have enough things to
put in my storage cubes validated in the
purchase they give the illusion that I
care about organizing my life even
though the storage cubes tend to add
more clutter than organization but hey
that's like children right I give the
illusion that
together but really they just had so
much clutter to your life next that this
is a box that I got from Joss and main
calm I know what's in it but you don't
so I thought I'd open it on camera for
you guys hold on a second
Thanks she's nailing it already and we
what is it well it's a fake trees smells
like a warehouse cool this is an adult
essential because why should I continue
a cycle of self-hate by trying to bring
real nature into my house and ultimately
killing it when I can have fake nature
and imitation is the highest form of
flattery
right so nature I think you're great
well there you go guys there are some of
my adult centrioles that I've ordered
off of the internet I hope that these
helped you in either handling your
already adult life or preparing for your
soon to be adult life remember this is
adult
oh also I got this in London when I was
there last week if you're really curious
as to what an adult looks like this is
it I don't know
remember that you can vote for me in the
Teen Choice Awards for a choice web star
female by going on the website teen
choice chain Joyce com
I think Teen Choice Awards com one of
those it'll be in the description also
you can tweet an Instagram and post on
Facebook
hashtag choice web star female at grace
Helbig every day up until the awards
this Sunday
this is a child's version and is hurting
my throat in my head and my image